okay so i i'm going to
uh talk about a new uh research effort
uh that i call hybridizing machine
learning just to talk about some of the
the things that are relevant for us in
the
insurance industry but i thought it'd be
useful just because a lot of people are
not familiar with what a re-insurer is
or
what an uh how that relates to the
insurance industry just to talk briefly
about that first i'm actually
with the swiss re institute uh i also
head up the the research and engagement
uh component of the swiss re institute
we have
offices around the world uh usually i'm
i'm
spending some of my time in san
francisco and new york and
and some of our offices in asia but uh
obviously now i'm
grounded in zurich which is not
necessarily a bad place to be
uh but uh we we are the the r d
component
of the reinsurer and for those of you
not familiar
with how the the industry is set up our
clients are actually
other insurance companies so direct
insurers take specific types of risk
and uh this is a quote that i like going
all the way back to the 20th century
that you know essentially without uh
insurance and effectively reinsurers
it'd be very hard
to take very large risks such as
building skyscrapers but also
ensuring hurricanes ensuring earthquakes
uh all the big risks and we essentially
make money
by allocating capital across uh
different types of risk categories and
then
essentially collecting the premiums and
investing those
in our our asset portfolio so that we
have money to pay out
when when the the downside events occur
so there's lots of
prediction pattern recognition that's
generally a component of insurance
historically it's been driven by the
actuarial
science but in recent years
there's been a shift in the industry
where we think
uh i mean we still we still try to
understand the risks and cover them
but that's becoming much more now
predict and prevent
and as a consequence that the we're
looking into much more than just
insurance and and some of these new
modeling techniques we think could be
quite effective in facilitating new
businesses
that we like to call resilience as a
service now to get there
uh there's a lot of hurdles in the real
world that you don't face
in in academia and actually i'm i'm also
an academic so i kind of understand both
sides of this this picture
but one of the big things is a lot of
the data that's quite useful
for these calculations are subject to
very
strict uh privacy regulations in europe
we have something called gdpr
that restricts how we can use data and
so this area of confidential computing i
just mentioned this because
it's becoming a bigger and bigger issue
and
there's still a number of paths of
research which
uh we're involved in some i don't have
time to go in through
go through the details but uh in
in broad terms you're either trying to
create trusted execution environments
in hardware such as intel's sgx
protocols
uh on their chips or you're trying to
manipulate
uh fully homomorphically encrypted data
there's a few other things you can
create trusted execution environments
and clouds
et cetera but this is a real issue and
so this is actually one dimension of
hybridization
whatever we do on the machine
intelligence it often has to be
hybridized with some kind of
confidential computing now there's one
path that we're
quite excited about we have a few
projects underway
that that facilitates uh this type of
confidential computing using
edge compute services or federated
learning
uh and if i had more time i could go
into the details
with this is still very much in the
early stages and
and we're seeing challenges deploying it
at enterprise scale which is a common
uh theme for uh reinsurance but the edge
computing the federated learning for
those of you interested in this area
this this is
this is quite important at least we
think to the future of how we can
deploy on these large enterprise
networks that we're part of
now uh one of my favorite authors is an
evolutionary biologist
by the game by the the name of eo wilson
and he was one time
quoted as saying you know humans have
paleolithic emotions medieval
institutions and god-like technologies
now if i take the analog in my industry
we have poorly curated data
and actually we have a lot of it but
it's it's uh it's not curated very well
we've got fragmented technology
architectures and then we've got a whole
bunch of god-like algorithms
and one of the challenges that we have
is we see a lot of innovative stuff out
of academia
out of our startup partners these
godlike algorithms but not enough people
thinking about how do you deal
with incomplete data how do you deal
with poorly curated
data and fragmented architectures this
is a real issue
and so i i make a big distinction
between
the ability to run some kind of a
an algorithm whether it be reinforcement
learning or deep learning
where you've got lots of data versus the
world that i live in
where i actually have lots of data but
it's just not well managed
and so that's that's why we're we find
these hybridized machine learning
approaches to be quite
interesting and and we have a a new
project area which we
loosely call the risk intelligence
factory where we're trying to take
a lot of these different networks that
are developing
many of them are implementing
distributed ledgers or blockchains
uh we have lots of internal data trying
to run that through confidential
computing
and then converting that into some kind
of resilience as a service
now this is an example of uh
a candidate architecture that's actually
something we're developing
uh together with a partner and this is
where you essentially
you start with some kind of a
physics-based model
such as say a hydrodynamic model for
urban resilience
and then you layer on top of that in a
in
a hybrid hybridized way different kinds
of machine learning
and this is something we're still
exploring could be reinforcement
learning
could be other kinds of approaches and
then
uh migrating that over to a simulation
setup that would allow us to look at
things like
what happens to an urban area when a
large flood
comes through or what happens when
there's a large earthquake
now if you look at the modeling in the
space you either have
very primitive actuarial models that are
that are based on parametrizations that
are mostly out of date particularly in
the context of climate change although
they're trying to update those
and then you have some people attempting
to run
i would say loosely supervised or almost
unsupervised approaches
but that often doesn't work real well
and then the straight physics-based
models
tend to be not granular enough to look
at uh
certain types of risks so this is an
example where this hybridization
can potentially really pay dividends at
least in in the risk assessment that
we're looking at
and then if you think if you move to the
other side of our balance sheet so that
that's
thinking more in terms of the liability
side if you move to our asset side of
our balance sheet often what we're
trying to do is predict certain types of
uh financial market variables such as
inflation such as interest rates
uh et cetera and hybrid is eight
sorry two minutes but
the hybridization uh here is really
about taking for example
subject matter expertise and
incorporating it
uh with some kind of behavioral cloning
or bayesian
updating and then potentially sticking
that inside of a reinforcement learning
harness
so that would be another idea that we
have for hybridization
these are all discussions that we're
having we're looking for people
interested in these types of projects so
this is why
you know i raised these points so just
in the end
at least from our perspective it's
important to realize that enterprise
scale is quite important
i've seen many uh promising algorithms
fail when we try to deploy them
end-to-end and enterprise uh contacts
because the latency
is too is too long and the costs are too
high either in terms of compute
or time uh and often we're dealing
with with just very fragmented data
value chains so that has to be taken
into account
and the confidential computing is is
always underlying
everything so these hybrid models we
believe could be
uh quite useful if we can figure out how
to make them work
so i will finish there and i don't know
if i have time for questions but
thank you very much for the opportunity
to present fantastic
thanks jeff